let's say that you've got some matrix
see trying my best to bold it to make
sure you realize that this is a matrix
and let's say that we know that it has a
a rose and B columns so it's an a by B a
by B matrix and let's say that we are
going to multiply it by some identity
matrix some identity matrix once again
let me do my best attempt to bold this
right over here so we're going to
multiply the identity matrix I times C
and of course we are going to get C
again because that's the identity matrix
that's the property of the entity matrix
and of course C we already know is an a
by B matrix a rows and B columns and B
columns now what are going what based on
this what are the dimensions of I going
to be and I encourage you to pause this
video and think about it on your own so
we've already done this exercise a
little bit where we first looked at
identity matrices but now we're doing it
with a very we're multiplying the
identity matrix times a very general
matrix we don't even i'm just even
speaking in generalities about its
dimensions well one thing we know is
that matrix multiplication is only
defined is if the columns the number of
columns of the first matrix is equal to
the number of rows of the second Matrix
so this one has a rows so this one's
going to have a columns it's going to
have a columns so it's going to have a
columns now how many rows is this one
going to have well we already know that
matrix multiplication is only defined if
the number of columns on the first
matrix is equal to the number of rows on
the second one and we know that the
product gets its number of rows we know
the product gets its number of rows from
the number of rows of the first matrix
being multiplied so the product has a
rows then the identity matrix right over
here has two
have a rose now what's interesting about
this when we first got introduced to
identity major matrices we were
multiplying we picked out a three by
three example and we got a three by
three identity matrix
what's interesting about what we've just
proven to ourselves is the identity
matrix for any matrix even a non-square
matrix a and B could be two different
values the identity matrix for any
matrix is going to be a square matrix
it's going to have it's going to have
the same number of rows and the same
number of columns and so when we think
about identity matrices we can really
just say well you know is this is this
the identity matrix that is a four by
four is it a three by three is it a two
by two or even a one by one and so you
don't even so the convention isn't even
to write identity 2 by 2 is equal to 1 0
0 1 the convention is actually just
write I to because you know it's going
to be a 2 by 2 it's a 2 well it's going
to be a 2 by 2 matrix so it's going to
be 1 0 0 1 identity 5 it's going to be a
5 by 5 matrix so it's going to be 1 1 2
3 4 0 1 2 1 2 3 0 0 1 1 0 0 0 you get
the idea 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 0 0 1 just like
that the whole point here is just to
realize that your identity matrix is
always going to be a square matrix and
it works even when you're multiplying
non square other matrices